It's peak pollination season, and my business is scaling fast. To keep the nectar flowing, I need a phone plan with top priority data speed. That's why I chose GoogleFi Wireless. My connections stay strong even when the hive is buzzing. Plus, unlimited plans started $35 a month. Now that's a deal that doesn't stay. Explore GoogleFi Wireless plans today. Plus taxes and government fees.
现在是授粉高峰期，我的业务正在快速扩张。为了保持花蜜源源不断，我需要一个拥有最高优先级数据速度的手机套餐。这就是我选择 GoogleFi Wireless 的原因。即使在蜂巢忙碌时，我的连接依然保持强劲。此外，无限流量套餐每月仅需 35 美元起。这可是一个不会一直有的优惠。立即探索 GoogleFi Wireless 套餐。另需缴纳税费和政府费用。
GoogleFi Wireless is not subject to data traffic deprioritization during times of high network usage. For many people seeking mental health care, finding the right treatment can be a slow, frustrating process. Clinicians may have to try several different medications and therapies over months or even years until, through trial and error, they land on something that works. But what if that could work differently? What if clinicians could look at a person's symptoms, daily patterns, and brain activity, and pinpoint from the beginning, which treatments are most likely to help. Today we're going to talk to two researchers working toward that goal in the emerging field of precision or personalized mental health care. So what exactly is precision mental
GoogleFi Wireless 在网络使用高峰期不会受到数据流量降速的影响。对于许多寻求心理健康护理的人来说，找到合适的治疗方法可能是一个缓慢且令人沮丧的过程。临床医生可能需要经过数月甚至数年的反复试验，尝试多种不同的药物和疗法，才能找到有效的方法。但如果情况可以有所不同呢？如果临床医生能够从一开始就观察一个人的症状、日常模式和大脑活动，并精准地找出最有可能提供帮助的治疗方法，那会怎样？今天，我们将与两位致力于实现这一目标的科研人员进行交流，他们所处的领域是新兴的精准或个性化心理健康护理。那么，究竟什么是精准心理
health care? How might tools like digital assessments and brain scans help match people with the right therapy? What mental health conditions are researchers looking at? What data privacy and other issues do these new methods raise? And how could they change the experience of patients, and clinicians going forward. Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills.
健康护理？数字评估和脑部扫描等工具如何帮助人们匹配合适的疗法？研究人员正在关注哪些心理健康状况？这些新方法引发了哪些数据隐私及其他问题？它们又将如何改变患者和临床医生的未来体验？欢迎收听《心理学谈话》，这是美国心理学会的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯。
I have two guests today. First is Dr. Zachary Cohen, an assistant professor of psychology and director of the personalized treatment lab at the University of Arizona. His research uses data-driven approaches to answer the questions how and for whom do treatments work. He has published dozens of peer-reviewed research papers and was named a rising star by the Association for Psychological Science in 2022. His work seeks to improve mental health treatment, accessibility, and outcomes, particularly for underserved populations.
今天我有两位嘉宾。第一位是扎卡里·科恩博士，他是亚利桑那大学心理学助理教授，也是个性化治疗实验室的主任。他的研究利用数据驱动的方法来回答治疗方法是如何起作用的以及对谁起作用的问题。他发表了数十篇同行评审的研究论文，并于 2022 年被心理科学协会评为“明日之星”。他的工作旨在改善心理健康治疗、可及性和治疗效果，特别是针对服务不足的人群。
Next is Dr. Leanne Williams, a professor of psychiatry and behavioral sciences at Stanford University, and the founding director of Stanford Center for Precision Mental Health and Wellness. She's internationally known for her work using neuroimaging and computational approaches to identify brain circuit biotypes of depression and anxiety. These are patterns that could help guide more targeted treatment. Dr. Williams has authored numerous scientific articles and led major interdisciplinary initiatives to integrate neuroscience with mental health care with the goal of creating more personalized and effective treatment pathways.
接下来是莉安·威廉姆斯博士，她是斯坦福大学精神病学和行为科学教授，也是斯坦福精准心理健康与健康中心的创始主任。她因利用神经影像学和计算方法识别抑郁症和焦虑症的大脑回路生物型而享誉国际。这些模式有助于指导更具针对性的治疗。威廉姆斯博士撰写了大量科学文章，并领导了多项跨学科倡议，旨在将神经科学与心理健康护理相结合，目标是创造更个性化、更有效的治疗途径。
Dr. Williams, Dr. Cohen, thank you for. for joining me today. It's a great pleasure to be here, Kim. Thank you for having us. Let's start as we often do on this podcast with a definition. I talk briefly in the introduction about precision mental health care, but I'd like to hear how you define it in your research. How does it differ from the way most mental health conditions are diagnosed and treated right now? Precision mental health really comes down to understanding why someone's struggling, so not just about what they're feeling. When we're thinking about precision mental health informed by what we know about the brain from neuroscience,
威廉姆斯博士、科恩博士，感谢你们今天参加节目。金，很高兴来到这里，谢谢你们邀请我们。我们像往常一样，从定义开始。我在介绍中简要谈到了精准心理健康护理，但我很想听听你们在研究中是如何定义它的。它与目前大多数心理健康状况的诊断和治疗方式有何不同？精准心理健康归根结底是要了解某人为何挣扎，而不仅仅是关于他们的感受。当我们思考以神经科学对大脑的了解为基础的精准心理健康时，
we're really aiming to understand the root cause of someone's experienced symptoms. And the second piece of precision is that we're using some form of objective test. That's to get at the root cause and then to guide more specific treatment choices. And in my case, I'm focusing on brain imaging to get at that root cause. cause and measure it precisely so we can personalise treatments. But there are certainly other ways to go about this as well. People are often feeling a lot of frustration because despite the available personalization and certainly very dedicated clinicians and therapists, it can end up being a trial and error cycle of trying one treatment, waiting a few months and trying another. And so
我们实际上是在努力理解某人所经历症状的根本原因。精准的第二个要素是，我们使用某种形式的客观测试。这是为了找到根本原因，然后指导更具体的治疗选择。就我而言，我专注于脑成像来找到那个根本原因，并精确地测量它，以便我们能够个性化治疗。但当然还有其他方法可以做到这一点。人们常常感到非常沮丧，因为尽管有现成的个性化方案，而且临床医生和治疗师也非常敬业，但最终可能会陷入一种反复试验的循环：尝试一种治疗，等待几个月，然后再尝试另一种。所以
One of the goals of being able to use objective measures and data is to really get answers much sooner and expedite this process of finding the right treatment for the right person. What are the technological advances that have made this possible? I mean, what are you looking at when you're really trying to pinpoint this type of treatment? In my case, one of the huge advances has been the twin development of very sophisticated, abilities to deal with a lot of data and specifically advanced ways of imaging the brain directly, which means we can use functional magnetic resonance imaging, which looks at how the brain is functioning, how it's using its fuel, how it's using its oxygen to function, and we can track these very important ways that the brain functions for managing our emotions,
能够使用客观测量和数据的一个目标是更快地获得答案，并加快为合适的人找到合适治疗方法的过程。有哪些技术进步使这一切成为可能？我的意思是，当你真正试图精准定位这种治疗时，你在看什么？就我而言，巨大的进步之一是处理大量数据的非常复杂的能力，特别是直接成像大脑的先进方法，这意味着我们可以使用功能性磁共振成像，它观察大脑是如何运作的，它是如何使用燃料的，它是如何使用氧气来运作的，我们可以追踪这些对管理我们的情绪非常重要的大脑功能方式，
or feeling our emotions, our thoughts, and so on. And a big advance has been mapping the human brain and these functional networks. They're like superhighways of the brain. And they govern the very important functions that get disrupted in conditions like depression or anxiety or post-traumatic stress. And now we have the capacity to have a window into how those
或者感受我们的情绪、我们的想法等等。一个巨大的进步是绘制了人类大脑和这些功能网络。它们就像大脑的“高速公路”。它们管理着在抑郁症、焦虑症或创伤后应激障碍等疾病中受到干扰的非常重要的功能。现在我们有能力窥探这些
circuits and networks are functioning in real time for someone experiencing depression, for example, and really pinpoint where is the disruption occurring that's driving their experience of depression? And that's something that has been advancing over the past decade, but in the last few years, I've been very fortunate to be part of developing a process and a method by which we can take that information and quantify and interpret it for each individual so we can identify their particular pattern of disruption. And that's what I call biotypes in my work. I've followed Dr. Williams' work for a long time and admired it, and it feels like science fiction. It's this really advanced and creative approach to understanding the brain.
回路和网络在某人经历抑郁症时是如何实时运作的，并真正查明导致他们抑郁体验的干扰发生在哪里。这是过去十年一直在进步的事情，但在过去几年里，我非常有幸参与开发了一个过程和方法，通过它我们可以获取这些信息，并为每个人进行量化和解释，这样我们就可以识别他们特定的干扰模式。这就是我在工作中称之为“生物型”的东西。我关注威廉姆斯博士的工作很长时间了，非常钦佩它，这感觉就像科幻小说。这是一种非常先进和创造性的理解大脑的方法。
the advances that have allowed my work to start to answer these questions are a lot less complicated in some ways. When I got into this field over a decade ago, I went to oncologists to ask how had they made progress in the treatment of cancer? And the example or the explanation they gave was that in child cancer, everyone who was being treated was being treated at an academic institution or a Center of Excellence where they were on the same protocol so they could aggregate the data and learn from everyone. And the problem in mental health research was that we had these small trials, there was no coordination of measurement, and we really just didn't have enough data to be able to build the predictive models that would tell us
允许我的工作开始回答这些问题的进展在某些方面要简单得多。十多年前我进入这个领域时，我曾去请教肿瘤学家，问他们是如何在癌症治疗方面取得进展的。他们给出的例子或解释是，在儿童癌症中，所有接受治疗的人都在学术机构或卓越中心接受治疗，他们遵循相同的方案，因此他们可以汇总数据并向所有人学习。而心理健康研究的问题在于，我们有这些小规模的试验，没有测量方面的协调，我们确实没有足够的数据来构建预测模型，告诉我们
who's going to respond to which treatment. And the big advance, or one of the big advance, that we've had, has, as Dr. Williams mentioned, been the ability to aggregate data. So we've collected the data from over 60 randomized control trials looking at depression treatment outcomes. We're also able to aggregate data from smartphones and other assessment approaches that allow us to measure people at scale. And by getting more data, we're finally able to start uncovering these patterns of response. Let me ask you, Dr. William, so you've mentioned using fMRI. Now, if I go to my psychotherapist because I'm depressed, he or she doesn't have access to an fMRI machine. So how does an individual clinician
谁会对哪种治疗有反应。正如威廉姆斯博士所提到的，我们取得的重大进展之一是汇总数据的能力。因此，我们收集了来自 60 多项观察抑郁症治疗结果的随机对照试验的数据。我们还能够汇总来自智能手机和其他评估方法的数据，使我们能够大规模地测量人们。通过获得更多数据，我们终于能够开始揭示这些反应模式。让我问你，威廉姆斯博士，你提到了使用功能性磁共振成像（fMRI）。现在，如果我因为抑郁去看心理治疗师，他或她无法使用 fMRI 机器。那么个人临床医生如何
apply what you are learning? I love that question, Kim. It's something I think about almost every day. And part of my work is very much focused on how we build the connection. that you're talking about. So your therapist, my therapist, anyone's therapist, would have a way of referring for a scan and making that possible and making it widely available. And I think of a model like migraine screening, which we could think of migraines. They're about 10% of the population or affecting about 10% of the population. and there's the availability of getting an MRI scan for migraines,
应用你们正在学习的知识呢？我喜欢这个问题，金。这是我几乎每天都在思考的事情。我的部分工作非常专注于我们如何建立你所说的联系。所以你的治疗师、我的治疗师、任何人的治疗师，都应该有一种方式来转诊进行扫描，使之成为可能，并使其广泛可用。我想到了像偏头痛筛查这样的模型，我们可以考虑偏头痛。它们大约占人口的 10%，或者影响大约 10% 的人口，并且有进行偏头痛核磁共振扫描的条件，
simile, epilepsy, other types of conditions. So we've been building the workflow, which clearly doesn't exist right now, at least not beyond a couple of clinics that we've been fortunate to set up a system for referral in. But working on those workflows, so they could be built in in a way that's, obviously integrated, reimbosable, practical, all of the aspects that would be needed.
类似地，癫痫，其他类型的疾病。所以我们一直在构建工作流程，这显然目前还不存在，至少在我们要建立转诊系统的几个诊所以外是不存在的。但我们正在研究这些工作流程，以便它们能以一种显然是整合的、可报销的、实用的方式构建，即所有需要的方面。
So we have this system, we call it the Stanford Etzieri image processing system, and it's designed to be implemented in a clinical workflow, not just in academic centers, but in the community as well. And so very excited to make that happen. I was at a meeting earlier this week in D.C. where ARPAH, the Advanced Research Project and Health Administration, was kicking off a $100 million precision treatment initiative. And there were companies there that were presenting mailable, disposable EEG that they can send in the mail. the patient puts it on their head with easily administered gel stickies, and it can be uploaded via a smartphone. And so I think although fMRI is not yet there, it's possible that in the future these things will be more accessible. Right.
所以我们有这个系统，我们称之为斯坦福 Etzieri 图像处理系统，它旨在不仅在学术中心，而且在社区的临床工作流程中实施。所以非常高兴能实现这一点。本周早些时候我在华盛顿参加了一个会议，高级研究计划与健康管理局（ARPAH）正在启动一项 1 亿美元的精准治疗计划。会上有一些公司展示了可以通过邮件寄送的可邮寄、一次性脑电图（EEG）设备。患者用易于使用的凝胶贴纸将其贴在头上，就可以通过智能手机上传数据。所以我认为虽然 fMRI 还没有达到那个程度，但未来这些东西可能会更容易获得。对。
Wow, that's really sci-fi. It is. It is happening, though. So many of us are walking around with smartphones and smart watches and aura rings and things like that so that we're collecting all of this. information. Is there some way of getting that, say, to your therapist or medical provider so that some of these markers can be spotted? I think that's the goal. What needs to happen before that can be useful is we need to establish what the actual value of that information is. We need to develop the actual biomarkers, or we sometimes call these things digital phenotypes. The things that tell us, okay, what does that information actually mean and how can we make sure that it's reliable,
哇，那真是科幻小说。确实是。不过它正在发生。我们许多人随身带着智能手机、智能手表、Oura 戒指之类的东西，所以我们正在收集所有这些信息。有没有什么方法可以把这些信息传给你的治疗师或医疗提供者，以便发现其中的一些标记？我认为这就是目标。在这些信息变得有用之前需要发生的是，我们需要确定这些信息的实际价值。我们需要开发实际的生物标志物，或者我们有时称这些东西为“数字表型”。那些告诉我们“好的，这些信息实际上意味着什么，以及我们如何确保它是可靠的”的东西，
that it's generalizable, that it's not biased towards certain populations. So once we've done that work, I think that's a really useful pipeline that you're imagining. Now, what exactly is a digital phenotype? I know you're doing a lot of work in that area, Dr. Cohen. What does that mean? How would I know what my digital phenotype is? Can I find that out? Yeah. So, We think about these important markers or pieces of information that we might be able to capture via passive signals, for example, from your smartphone or wearable device. So your wearable device has an accelerometer. It also often has a heart rate monitor and can collect these things that are very sort of fine-grained, right?
它是可推广的，它不会对某些人群产生偏见。所以一旦我们完成了这项工作，我认为这就是你所想象的一个非常有用的渠道。那么，什么是数字表型？我知道你在那个领域做了很多工作，科恩博士。那意味着什么？我怎么知道我的数字表型是什么？我能查出来吗？是的。所以，我们考虑这些重要的标记或信息片段，我们可能能够通过被动信号捕获它们，例如，来自你的智能手机或可穿戴设备。所以你的可穿戴设备有一个加速度计。它通常还有一个心率监测器，可以收集这些非常细粒度的东西，对吧？
They're not telling you what your sleep is, but we can use that information to then say, okay, well, when somebody isn't moving a lot and no light is being sensed and there's no sound, we are pretty confident that they're asleep. And so then we can develop a digital phenotype of somebody who is a healthy sleeper, somebody who is having primary insomnia, where they're having difficulty falling asleep, or terminal insomnia, where they're having difficulty waking up. And so those digital phenotypes are how we take the raw information from these different devices and capture meaningful constructs that are then related to health outcomes or that can predict treatment response. Your summer starts now with Memorial Day deals at the Home Depot. It's time to fire up summer cookouts with the next grill for burner gas grill on special buy for only $199. and entertain all season with the Hampton Bay West Grove
它们并没有告诉你你的睡眠情况，但我们可以利用这些信息来判断，好的，当某人没有太多移动，没有感知到光线，也没有声音时，我们非常有把握他们正在睡觉。因此，我们可以开发一个数字表型，针对那些健康睡眠者，或者患有原发性失眠症（入睡困难）的人，或者终末性失眠症（难以醒来）的人。因此，这些数字表型就是我们如何从这些不同的设备中获取原始信息，并捕获与健康结果相关或可以预测治疗反应的有意义的结构。你的夏天从家得宝（The Home Depot）的阵亡将士纪念日促销开始。是时候用特价仅 199 美元的 Next Grill 四头燃气烤架开启夏季烧烤了，并用汉普顿湾 West Grove
seven-piece outdoor dining set for only $499. This Memorial Day get low prices guaranteed at the Home Depot. While supplies last, price invalid May 14th or May 27th U.S. only exclusions apply, see Home Depot.com slash price match for details. You said this place was steps from the water.
七件套户外餐桌椅套装（仅售 499 美元）尽情娱乐整个季节。这个阵亡将士纪念日，在家得宝享受低价保证。售完即止，价格有效期为 5 月 14 日至 5 月 27 日，仅限美国，排除条款适用，详情请参阅 HomeDepot.com/pricematch。你说这个地方离水边只有几步之遥。
We just haven't found the steps yet. How much did we save? Enough. Enough to get lost. Or you could book a lot. stay with Hilton. Welcome to your oceanfront room. Just steps from the water. The Hilton sale is on now. Book on Hilton.com or the Hilton app and save up to 20% to get the stay you expected. When you want savings, not surprises. It matters where you stay. Hilton for this day. We're going to take a short
我们只是还没找到那几步路。我们省了多少钱？够了。足够去迷路了。或者你可以预订希尔顿酒店的住宿。欢迎来到你的海滨房间。离水边只有几步之遥。希尔顿促销活动现已开始。在 Hilton.com 或希尔顿应用程序上预订，最高可享 8 折优惠，获得你期待的住宿体验。当你想要节省开支，而不是意外时，你住哪里很重要。希尔顿，为了这次住宿。我们要进行短暂的
break. When we return, I'll talk more with Dr. Williams about the six biotypes of depression and anxiety that she's identified. So Dr. Williams, I want to ask you. you mentioned earlier biotypes. I know that a lot of your work is focused on that, and you're developing biotypes for depression and anxiety. How does this research work? What is it that you have found? Yes, we found six biotypes that would account for 90% of the variability that you see underlying that broad category of depression and anxiety, a broad categories. So let's focus on depression. Very rarely do people share the symptoms of depression. They might have a couple in common, but there's a lot of different individual experiences in how someone, how their depression is
休息。回来后，我将与威廉姆斯博士更多地讨论她确定的六种抑郁症和焦虑症生物型。所以威廉姆斯博士，我想问你。你之前提到了生物型。我知道你的很多工作都集中在那上面，你正在开发抑郁症和焦虑症的生物型。这项研究是如何运作的？你发现了什么？是的，我们发现了六种生物型，它们可以解释你在抑郁症和焦虑症这一广泛类别下看到的 90% 的变异性。所以让我们关注抑郁症。人们很少有相同的抑郁症状。他们可能有一些共同点，但每个人的抑郁表现方式有很多不同的个人体验。
manifested for them. And so underneath that, what we see in the brain is extraordinary variability in what is the underlying root cause of the types of symptoms being experienced. When we look at these brain circuits that I was talking about before, there's at least six of them that are strongly implicated in depression and in the way that treatments work. And so if we measure those six different circuits, we can actually identify six different types of depression. And this is a little like, if we think of an analogy, it's a little like thinking of a broader category like breast cancer in cancer medicine, but once you image the tumor or you get the genome, genetic information, you can identify a subtype or
因此，在这些症状之下，我们在大脑中看到的是所经历症状类型的根本原因存在巨大的变异性。当我们观察我之前谈到的这些大脑回路时，至少有六个与抑郁症以及治疗起作用的方式密切相关。因此，如果我们测量这六个不同的回路，我们实际上可以识别出六种不同类型的抑郁症。这有点像，如果我们想一个类比，这有点像考虑癌症医学中像乳腺癌这样更广泛的类别，但一旦你对肿瘤进行成像或获得基因组、遗传信息，你就可以识别出该癌症类型中的一个亚型。
within that type of cancer. So we're doing that with biotypes. And we could say, for example, you might have one circuit that's disrupted, one that's called negative affect. It is a part of the brain that responds to your negative emotions like sadness. It responds to potential threats. If it gets switched on and stays switched on for too long, people might have the experience of being very acutely, almost a sense of panic, a more trauma type of depression, whereas another type of depression would involve a different part of the brain.
所以我们正在用生物型做这件事。我们可以说，例如，你可能有一个回路受到干扰，一个被称为“负面情感”。它是大脑中对你的负面情绪（如悲伤）做出反应的部分。它对潜在的威胁做出反应。如果它被开启并保持开启时间过长，人们可能会有非常敏锐的体验，几乎是一种恐慌感，一种创伤类型的抑郁症，而另一种类型的抑郁症会涉及大脑的不同部分。
And you can see people who describe having cognitive fog, and it will be a different frontal part of the brain. And crucially, those different biotypes that we've identified are very, very specific in how they can predict what treatment. you're likely to respond to. And those are medications, behavior therapy, techniques we call neuromodulation, like transcranial magnetic stimulation. And some of these newer treatments we hear talked about, like ketamine or even psilocybin, they give us a very good indication of who will do well on those different types of treatments. And that's the way we can expedite. The
你可以看到人们描述有“认知迷雾”，那将是大脑不同的额叶部分。至关重要的是，我们确定的这些不同生物型在预测你可能对什么治疗有反应方面非常、非常具体。这些包括药物、行为疗法、我们称之为神经调节的技术，如经颅磁刺激。以及我们听到谈论的一些较新的治疗方法，如氯胺酮甚至裸盖菇素，它们给了我们很好的指示，说明谁会对这些不同类型的治疗有良好的反应。这就是我们可以加快
treatment choice. In our studies, we found if we use those biotypes to select treatment, we can actually get close to doubling their chances of getting better, each person's chances of getting better. And is this broadly understood among practitioners that depression is not like a single illness? There are different manifestations, as you've just said. I mean, if I go, again, and I'm talking for our listeners who maybe are being treated for depression, and perhaps their therapist has really no idea that these biotypes exist. So how do you get the right treatment other than, you know, you just keep trying different medications? You just keep trying different therapies.
治疗选择的方式。在我们的研究中，我们发现如果我们使用这些生物型来选择治疗，我们实际上可以使他们好转的机会增加近一倍，每个人好转的机会。从业者是否普遍理解抑郁症不是一种单一的疾病？正如你刚才所说，有不同的表现形式。我的意思是，如果我再次去就诊，我是为那些可能正在接受抑郁症治疗的听众说话，也许他们的治疗师根本不知道这些生物型的存在。那么，除了你只是不断尝试不同的药物，你只是不断尝试不同的疗法之外，你如何获得正确的治疗？
There's certainly a consensus that depression is very varied. In current practice, we do typically use the broader category, you know, the broader diagnostic category. of major depression or generalized anxiety inside of our diagnostic system, which is called the Diagnostic and Statistical Manual, DSM. There are some subcategories or specifiers that would say maybe it's this type of depression based on the symptoms. However, right now, the way that is practiced, the broader categories, decree or the specifiers don't directly determine what type of treatment might be selected.
人们当然达成了一种共识，即抑郁症是非常多样的。在目前的实践中，我们通常在我们的诊断系统（称为《精神疾病诊断与统计手册》，DSM）中使用重度抑郁症或广泛性焦虑症的更广泛的诊断类别。有一些子类别或说明符可能会说，根据症状，这可能是这种类型的抑郁症。然而，目前，这种实践方式，更广泛的类别，法令或说明符并不能直接决定可能选择什么类型的治疗。
So for most people, it's that broad category that's used. And it does act as a form of a one-size-fits-all, really, even though each clinician is clearly trying to understand each person's individual experience, but it does act more like a one-size-fits-all. And that's what's leading in many cases to that trial and error cycle. Dr. Colin, let me ask you, could these methods be used for prevention as well as treatments? In other words, could they help identify people who are at risk for different mental health conditions and maybe problems could be headed off before they become severe?
所以对大多数人来说，使用的是那个广泛的类别。它确实起到了一种“一刀切”的作用，尽管每位临床医生显然都在努力理解每个人的个人经历，但它确实表现得更像是一种“一刀切”。而在许多情况下，这正是导致那种反复试验循环的原因。科恩博士，让我问你，这些方法可以用于预防以及治疗吗？换句话说，它们能帮助识别有不同心理健康状况风险的人，并在问题变得严重之前将其扼杀在摇篮中吗？
Yeah, we know depression is highly recurrent and that an individual's likelihood of experiencing relapse increases with the number of episodes they have. So it's incredibly important to try and prevent the onset of depression. And exactly as you're describing, if we can identify either who is at risk for developing depression or if we can detect it when it's in its early phases before they're really impaired, before the symptoms get really bad, we can both reduce suffering and also be more efficient. And so we're actually working on that right now. Our colleague Iko Freed ran a large study in which he followed over 2,000 people without depression for a year and collected all of this rich data, including wearable information, and built an
是的，我们知道抑郁症极易复发，个人经历复发的可能性随着他们发作次数的增加而增加。因此，尝试预防抑郁症的发生极其重要。正如你所描述的那样，如果我们能识别出谁有患抑郁症的风险，或者如果我们能在它处于早期阶段、在他们真正受损、症状变得非常严重之前检测到它，我们既可以减少痛苦，也可以提高效率。所以我们实际上正在研究这个问题。我们的同事 Iko Freed 进行了一项大型研究，他跟踪了 2,000 多名没有抑郁症的人一年，并收集了所有这些丰富的数据，包括可穿戴设备信息，并构建了一个
algorithm that could predict who was at risk. And now what we're going to try and do is use that algorithm to say, can we intervene prior to the development in a way that is targeted? And if we can do that, hopefully we can really kind of make a big difference in the global burden of depression by stopping it before it starts. Now, both of you have focused a lot of your work on depression and anxiety, but are there other mental health conditions that this type of precision care could be helpful for? Absolutely. In my case, when I first was starting doing research, I focused on psychosis, particularly early onset of psychosis, and I have collaborators focusing on attention deficit disorders and PTSD. There's certainly been many, very exciting initiatives in those
可以预测谁有风险的算法。现在我们要尝试做的是使用该算法来判断，我们能否在发展之前以一种有针对性的方式进行干预？如果我们能做到这一点，希望我们能通过在抑郁症开始之前就阻止它，真正地对全球抑郁症负担产生重大影响。现在，你们俩都把很多工作集中在抑郁症和焦虑症上，但这种精准护理对其他心理健康状况有帮助吗？绝对有。就我而言，当我刚开始做研究时，我专注于精神病，特别是精神病的早期发作，我有合作者专注于注意力缺陷障碍和创伤后应激障碍。在这些领域当然有很多非常令人兴奋的倡议，
areas and I'm sure many others. As a field, it's been motivating to see how this precision approach is really becoming as close to mainstream as I've seen in a major advance in our field. So I see it happening across areas and maybe Dr. Cohen knows of others to highlight. Oh, I totally agree. And I think a related implication or manifestation of this is that we're also thinking about trans-diagnostic processes. And what I mean by that is something like rumination or worry. Those are things that occur in depression, but also in anxiety disorders. And so we're also thinking about how can we develop precision or targeted or personalized
我相信还有许多其他领域。作为一个领域，看到这种精准方法真的变得像我在我们领域看到的重大进展一样接近主流，这令人振奋。所以我看到它在各个领域发生，也许科恩博士知道其他值得强调的领域。哦，我完全同意。我认为这的一个相关含义或表现是，我们也在考虑“跨诊断过程”。我的意思是像反刍或担忧这样的事情。这些事情发生在抑郁症中，但也发生在焦虑症中。所以我们也在思考我们如何能够开发精准的、有针对性的或个性化的
approaches to help address rumination, whether it's in the context of depression or anxiety. And because we know that comorbidity is really the rule rather than the exception, meaning that people usually don't show up in the clinic with only depression or only panic disorder. Most people are actually going to show up meeting criteria for more than one disorder to have approaches that can help guide treatment in the context of comorbidity, and often those are approaches that are going to think about trans-diagnostic processes is really important. One of the reasons I focused on depression and made that choice to make the move is, for two reasons. One is much earlier than we expected, depression became the number one leading cause of disability in the world.
方法来帮助解决反刍问题，无论是在抑郁症还是焦虑症的背景下。而且因为我们知道共病确实是规则而不是例外，这意味着人们通常不会只带着抑郁症或只带着恐慌症出现在诊所。大多数人实际上会表现出符合不止一种疾病的标准，因此拥有可以在共病背景下指导治疗的方法，并且通常这些方法是会考虑跨诊断过程的方法，这非常重要。我专注于抑郁症并做出这一选择的原因有两个。一是比我们预期的要早得多，抑郁症成为了世界上导致残疾的第一大原因。
And that, to me, is both staggering and unacceptable. how many people's lives are being impacted. So it's really a big public need, health need, meaning people's quality of life and literally the number of years they're getting lost, that are being lost, to having their function disrupted and shortening of their actual years of life. And related to that is the fact that there are a lot of effective treatments but we do not know for whom to target, you know, who should we target them to.
对我来说，这既令人震惊又不可接受。有多少人的生活受到了影响。所以这确实是一个巨大的公共需求，健康需求，意味着人们的生活质量，以及他们实际上正在失去的年数，因为他们的功能受到干扰，实际寿命缩短。与此相关的事实是，有很多有效的治疗方法，但我们不知道针对谁，你知道，我们应该针对谁。
The other quick thought is that we do know and increasingly have evidence for this that conditions like depression are, have a bi-directional association with other medical conditions and de actors, risk factors. So risk factors for other chronic conditions, cardiac conditions, some neurological conditions. So really finding better solutions for depression, anxiety, other disorders will have a very widespread effect on improving health. So what do you both see as the biggest challenges in getting this research that you're doing out of the lab and into clinicians' offices? One of the things that I became frustrated by, in relation to my
另一个快速的想法是，我们确实知道并且越来越多地有证据表明，像抑郁症这样的疾病与其他医疗状况和因素具有双向关联。因此，其他慢性疾病、心脏疾病、一些神经系统疾病的风险因素。所以，真正为抑郁症、焦虑症和其他疾病找到更好的解决方案，将对改善健康产生非常广泛的影响。那么，你们俩认为将你们正在做的这项研究从实验室带到临床医生办公室面临的最大挑战是什么？我感到沮丧的事情之一，与我
own work was that if we develop these treatment selection models and we show that they're reliable and powerful and even if we're able to show that they can generalize to new populations, which is a much higher bar than is typically applied, the ability of the systems that exist to use that information is often shockingly limited. So if I have a model that says, somebody is going to respond better to cognitive behavioral therapy versus interpersonal therapy. You need to have a system in which both of those interventions are available. And a single clinician usually is only going to be comfortable treating one modality. If I'm in the care of a psychiatrist and the model says, you'll do better in cognitive behavioral therapy,
自己的工作有关，那就是如果我们开发这些治疗选择模型，并且我们证明它们是可靠和强大的，即使我们能够证明它们可以推广到新的人群（这比通常应用的门槛要高得多），现有系统使用这些信息的能力往往令人震惊地有限。所以如果我有一个模型说，某人对认知行为疗法比对人际关系疗法反应更好。你需要有一个系统，其中这两种干预措施都可用。而单一的临床医生通常只会对治疗一种模式感到舒适。如果我正在接受精神科医生的护理，而模型说，你在认知行为疗法中会做得更好，
well, is the psychiatrist going to be happy about that information? Are they going to use it? And so to me, there was a lack of actionability in our existing mental health care treatment systems. And that drove me to move towards more scalable treatment approaches like digital therapeutics, which can be made more widely available and where we have the ability to implement the personalization ourselves. Now, those aren't going to be a fit for everyone and for every disorder. We certainly have need for treatment, personalization and precision approaches at much higher levels of care and in different contexts. But to me, that was a big barrier that we're now hopefully trying to address.
那么，精神科医生会对这个信息感到高兴吗？他们会使用它吗？所以对我来说，我们现有的心理健康护理治疗系统缺乏可操作性。这促使我转向更具可扩展性的治疗方法，如数字疗法，它可以更广泛地提供，并且我们有能力自己实施个性化。现在，这些并不适合每个人和每种疾病。我们当然需要在更高水平的护理和不同背景下进行治疗个性化和精准方法。但对我来说，这是一个我们现在希望正在努力解决的巨大障碍。
Dr. Williams, what do you think are the barriers? I entirely agree about the systems level challenge in our area of health, psychology, psychiatry. we haven't had systems that incorporate these objective tests. So down to the level of making the referral or the way the EHR is set up, they're not currently set up for those. I actually took on that challenge, which is a different level to Dr. Cohen, and we have had success in being able to incorporate into the EHR. This is currently at a new clinic at Stanford, and there's a clinic in Italy doing it and a couple of others in the process of setting up,
威廉姆斯博士，你认为障碍是什么？我完全同意我们健康、心理学、精神病学领域在系统层面的挑战。我们还没有整合这些客观测试的系统。所以落实到转诊层面，或者电子健康记录（EHR）的设置方式，它们目前还没有为此设置。我实际上承担了那个挑战，这与科恩博士的层面不同，我们已经成功地将其整合到 EHR 中。这目前是在斯坦福的一个新诊所，意大利有一个诊所在做，还有其他几个正在设置过程中，
where there's a way of ordering the scans and the Stanford Etzeri biotyping system through the EHR. That took several years because it required actually building out a way to order it. It highlights the need for also regulatory changes. there you have new tools going through FDA for FDA approval. It highlights an educational challenge. So the new psychologists, psychiatrists and other therapists coming through to be trained in these approaches, I think I see a lot of excitement around that, but it will meet an update in the way that we train. The last thing I've observed has been interesting, which is often,
在那里有一种通过 EHR 订购扫描和斯坦福 Etzeri 生物分型系统的方法。这花了几年时间，因为它实际上需要构建一种订购方式。它强调了也需要监管变革。那里有新的工具通过 FDA 审批。它强调了一个教育挑战。所以新的心理学家、精神科医生和其他治疗师在接受这些方法的培训，我认为我看到了很多围绕这一点的兴奋，但它需要更新我们培训的方式。我观察到的最后一件事很有趣，那就是通常，
our studies are not actually designed with the clinic in mind. So even thinking about, you know, I realize some of the measures I use for measuring symptom outcomes or treatment outcomes are not the ones that a clinician would use. So really thinking about that level of harmonization as well. I think that's a great point. And in work led by a colleague Jamie Delgado, we did the first prospective validation that compared a clinical decision support tool that gave clinicians
我们的研究实际上并不是以诊所为中心设计的。所以即使考虑到，你知道，我意识到我用来测量症状结果或治疗结果的一些测量方法并不是临床医生会使用的那些。所以真正考虑那种协调水平也很重要。我认为这是一个很好的观点。在由同事杰米·德尔加多领导的工作中，我们进行了首次前瞻性验证，比较了一个临床决策支持工具，该工具为临床医生
and patients information about who would be most likely to respond to low-intensity psychological interventions and who needed a higher level of care like one-on-one CBT and showed that this information could actually improve patient outcome. So it was a land. landmark study, incredibly impressive work by Dr. Delgadoio and colleagues, but one of the really interesting things was when he went to implement the study, he met some understandable resistance from the clinicians where they said, why should we use this information? We've been treating our patients and making these decisions about who should go to low versus high intensity and what they should get when they get there.
和患者提供了关于谁最有可能对低强度心理干预做出反应，以及谁需要更高水平的护理（如一对一 CBT）的信息，并表明这些信息实际上可以改善患者的预后。所以这是一项里程碑式的研究，德尔加多博士和同事们的工作令人难以置信，但真正有趣的事情之一是，当他去实施这项研究时，他遇到了一些可以理解的来自临床医生的阻力，他们说，我们为什么要使用这些信息？我们一直在治疗我们的病人，并就谁应该接受低强度与高强度治疗以及他们到达那里时应该得到什么做出这些决定。
there was a sort of skepticism that needed to be overcome. And he came up with this brilliant intervention where, based on some of Paul Meals' work, this amazing psychologist who showed that our ability to simultaneously hold multiple factors in our head to make these complex or nuanced decisions is pretty limited. Like we can't really keep more than, I don't know, two or three things in our head. And so if I'm going to actually make a decision based on five or
有一种需要克服的怀疑态度。他想出了这个绝妙的干预措施，基于保罗·米尔斯的一些工作，这位了不起的心理学家证明了我们同时在脑海中保持多个因素以做出这些复杂或细微决定的能力是非常有限的。就像我们不能真的在脑海中保持超过，我不知道，两三件事。所以如果我真的要基于五个或
six factors, I can't do that. And he showed them in a workshop with the clinicians by having them try and do that and showing them how difficult it was. And so by doing that, as well as by really explaining how these systems work so that it's not a black box, so that the clinicians can have some insight into, well, this is why this recommendation is being made, that those sorts of interventions were necessary and powerful in getting the buy-in that's needed. Because if we develop these tools and clinicians and patients don't trust them or they're not on board with using them, then it's not going to really make a big impact. So I really love that work.
六个因素做出决定，我做不到。他在与临床医生的研讨会上通过让他们尝试这样做，并向他们展示这有多困难，向他们展示了这一点。因此，通过这样做，以及通过真正解释这些系统是如何工作的，以便它不是一个“黑匣子”，以便临床医生可以对“这就是为什么做出这个建议”有一些洞察，这些干预措施对于获得所需的认同是必要且强大的。因为如果我们开发了这些工具，而临床医生和患者不信任它们，或者他们不赞成使用它们，那么它就不会真正产生巨大的影响。所以我真的很喜欢那项工作。
And it shows really one of the barriers to getting these things used. That's fantastic work. And your point about being transparent and not having a black box, I think that is really crucial. I found that from the brain imaging side as well. And of course, as psychologists, I know you know how difficult it is to get people to change. You look at hospitals and they have historically had a lot of problems getting doctors to wash their hands and other medical professionals. So if hospitals can't get that behavior change, it's a little bit of hubris for us to think that it'll be easy to get clinicians to change the way they treat patients in mental health. What I have noticed, and maybe also Dr. Cohen has, there's a big push coming from the individuals themselves, from patients being aware because so much is available now through internet and so on.
它确实显示了让这些东西被使用的障碍之一。那真是太棒的工作了。关于透明且没有“黑匣子”的观点，我认为这确实至关重要。我从脑成像方面也发现了这一点。当然，作为心理学家，我知道你们知道让人们改变有多难。你看看医院，他们历史上在让医生洗手和其他医疗专业人员方面有很多问题。所以如果医院不能实现那种行为改变，我们认为让临床医生改变他们在心理健康中治疗病人的方式会很容易，这有点傲慢。我所注意到的是，也许科恩博士也注意到了，来自个人本身的巨大推动力，来自患者的意识，因为现在通过互联网等可以获得很多信息。
They're aware of the advances and there's so much that's been achieved through the research. So the demand is there and that I think will push from a different angle for. for really getting the advances into practice. And again, just from the viewpoint of our listeners, if I am somebody who is experiencing anxiety or depression, how would I access this type of treatment? Is there a place to go? Are there clinical trials?
他们意识到这些进展，并且通过研究已经取得了这么多成就。所以需求就在那里，我认为这将从一个不同的角度推动，真正将这些进展付诸实践。再次，仅从我们听众的角度来看，如果我是一个正在经历焦虑或抑郁的人，我该如何获得这种类型的治疗？有地方可以去吗？有临床试验吗？
Is there someplace I can go to get the treatment that you're talking about? So in our case, yes. So we do have the clinic at Stanford that does mean either being able to come in person to the clinic or being able to find a way to do at least part of it remotely. And that's a base from which we are setting up a broader network and we're actively planning that and very excited about it. The other possibility is through trials. So we have all of that information available on our website about how to express interest in trials and through the clinic itself.
有我可以去获得你所谈论的治疗的地方吗？所以就我们而言，是的。所以我们确实有斯坦福的诊所，这意味着要么能够亲自来到诊所，要么能够找到一种至少部分远程完成的方法。这是我们正在建立一个更广泛网络的基础，我们正在积极规划它，并对此感到非常兴奋。另一种可能性是通过试验。所以我们在我们的网站上提供了所有关于如何表达对试验的兴趣的信息，以及通过诊所本身。
Yeah, in terms of the sort of stuff that I'm involved in, using Dr. Delgado's model as an example, he's currently involved in large-scale dissemination and implementation trials, meaning evidence has been genera. that this can improve patient outcomes relative to the way that they were doing treatment allocation prior. And so now they're rolling it out to clinics across the United Kingdom. They have a national health system there that anyone who is depressed or anxious can get psychological care. And so this system triages over a million people a year, treats over 700,000 people a year. And so now in these clinics across the UK, that clinical decision support tool is being rolled out and studied to make sure that it continues to be effective in these new places and that clinicians are using it with fidelity and all that sort of thing. Just to wrap up, I want to ask if you have concerns about data privacy emerging from this work.
是的，就我参与的那类事情而言，以德尔加多博士的模型为例，他目前参与了大规模的传播和实施试验，这意味着证据已经生成，证明这可以改善患者的预后，相对于他们之前进行治疗分配的方式。所以现在他们正在将其推广到英国各地的诊所。他们那里有一个国家卫生系统，任何抑郁或焦虑的人都可以获得心理护理。所以这个系统每年分诊超过一百万人，每年治疗超过 70 万人。所以现在在英国各地的这些诊所中，该临床决策支持工具正在被推广和研究，以确保它在这些新地方继续有效，并且临床医生正在忠实地使用它等等。最后，我想问你们是否对这项工作产生的关于数据隐私的担忧。
I mean, there's so much information about us that's being collected right now. And I don't even know where it goes half the time. I mean, how should researchers and clinicians think about this issue and what should consumers know about protecting their own neurological data? This is something that scares me because it's outside my area of expertise and I can see the potential harm. And I don't know the system well enough to know how we stop it. But if you think about something like a predictive algorithm that says,
我的意思是，现在有太多关于我们的信息正在被收集。而且我有一半的时间甚至不知道这些信息去了哪里。我的意思是，研究人员和临床医生应该如何看待这个问题？消费者又该如何保护自己的神经数据？这让我感到害怕，因为它超出了我的专业领域，而且我能预见到潜在的危害。我也不够了解这个系统，不知道该如何阻止它。但如果你想到某种预测算法，它说，
who's going to be at risk for developing depression or other mental health problems, you can imagine that if an insurance company got a hold of that information and was able to make that determination without your consent, if they were able to scrape your social media data and then say, oh, well, we're not going to insure this person because they're at high risk for developing disorder XYZ, that that could be a problem.
谁有患抑郁症或其他心理健康问题的风险，你可以想象，如果一家保险公司掌握了这些信息，并且能够在未经你同意的情况下做出这种判断，如果他们能够抓取你的社交媒体数据，然后说，哦，好吧，我们不会为这个人投保，因为他们患XYZ疾病的风险很高，那这可能会成为一个问题。
Or your future employer could say, well, we've looked at all of your language from your social media, and based on that, we think you're likely to develop depression. I don't think we're going to hire you. That is scary to me. And I think these systems, when used for the good of the patient, can be incredibly powerful, but I can also see ways in which they could be used in ways that don't benefit the individual. Finally, I mean, this is the real wrap-up. Big research questions that you're still trying to answer. Dr. Williams, do you want to grab that one? Yeah, now this is a really exciting time. We are building on what we think of as a Framingham study for mental health. So there was a very
或者你未来的雇主可能会说，好吧，我们查看了你社交媒体上的所有言论，基于此，我们认为你很可能会患上抑郁症。我想我们不会录用你。这让我感到害怕。我认为这些系统在用于造福患者时，可以非常强大，但我也能看到它们可能以不利于个人的方式被使用。最后，我的意思是，这是真正的总结。你们仍在试图回答的重大研究问题。威廉姆斯博士，你想回答这个问题吗？是的，现在是一个非常令人兴奋的时刻。我们正在建立我们认为是心理健康领域的弗雷明汉研究。所以有一个非常
influential impactful study called Framingham that really changed cardiology from not knowing what underlies heart disease at all. It was the same observation, FDR, FDR, and his death from heart disease really initiated that project. So what we're thinking of is Framingham for mental health, which means very, very large-scale national partnerships with research and with health networks, where we take the evidence that we have, which is robust enough, to prospectively identify which treatment to start someone on and to do a very large study where you're actually able to compare back to back
有影响力的研究叫弗雷明汉研究，它真正改变了心脏病学，从完全不知道心脏病的潜在原因开始。这是同样的观察，富兰克林·罗斯福，富兰克林·罗斯福死于心脏病真正启动了那个项目。所以我们想到的是心理健康的弗雷明汉研究，这意味着与研究机构和医疗网络进行非常大规模的全国性合作，我们利用我们现有的证据，这些证据已经足够稳健，可以前瞻性地确定应该让某人开始哪种治疗，并进行一项非常大规模的研究，让你能够真正进行背靠背的比较
all the different available treatments we have across the different types of modalities and then follow people over time. So you're getting a good sense of, does this make a difference in the short term? Can we double the chances of getting better sooner? And then can we show sustained positive outcomes? and that would be across different types of treatments. Very excited about that. We have to really kind of accelerate this process,
我们拥有的所有不同类型的可用治疗方法，然后随着时间的推移跟踪人们。所以你会有一个很好的感觉，这在短期内有区别吗？我们能将更快好转的机会加倍吗？然后我们能展示持续的积极结果吗？这将涵盖不同类型的治疗。对此我感到非常兴奋。我们必须真正加快这个过程，
we're very fortunate to have funds from an NIH initiative known as Impact MH, which is specifically designed to accelerate the link from the biotypes and other measures to the clinic. So it's an exciting time. And Dr. Kohn, what about you? I'm a mental health expert of sorts, and I know well a lot of the people who develop the most commonly used evidence-based psychotherapies. And when I try and get treatment for loved ones, for friends, it's a real challenge, even if they can self-pay. And so to me, that's such a huge barrier.
我们非常幸运地获得了美国国立卫生研究院（NIH）一项名为Impact MH的计划的资助，该计划专门旨在加速从生物型和其他指标到临床应用的联系。所以这是一个令人兴奋的时刻。科恩博士，你呢？我算是一位心理健康专家，我非常了解许多开发最常用循证心理疗法的人。当我试图为亲人、朋友寻求治疗时，这真是一个挑战，即使他们可以自费。所以对我来说，这是一个巨大的障碍。
if I struggle with all of my access and privilege to get good evidence-based psychological care for the people who are most important to me, imagine how challenging it is for people who don't have that knowledge and access, who are under-resourced. And so the big thing that I'm working on right now with my lab is to try and develop interventions that can really take the evidence-based care that we have. and make it more widely accessible, especially for underserved communities. And then not to just deliver evidence-based care, but to deliver personalized evidence-based care that's more engaging, that's more effective, and that can really move the needle on getting
如果我拥有所有的渠道和特权，却还在为我最重要的人获得良好的循证心理护理而挣扎，想象一下那些没有这些知识和渠道、资源不足的人面临的挑战有多大。所以，我和我的实验室目前正在做的最重要的事情就是尝试开发干预措施，真正利用我们现有的循证护理，并使其更广泛地普及，特别是对于服务不足的社区。而且不仅仅是提供循证护理，而是提供更具参与性、更有效、真正能推动改善人们状况并保持健康的个性化循证护理。
people well and keeping them well. Well, Dr. Williams, Dr. Cohen, I want to thank you for joining me. This is very important work that you're doing, so thank you so much. Thank you. It's a great pleasure. Yeah, thank you for having us. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at speakingofpsychology.org or on Apple, Spotify, YouTube, or wherever you get your podcasts. And if you like what you've heard, please subscribe and leave a review. If you have comments or ideas for future episodes, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org.
好吧，威廉姆斯博士，科恩博士，我要感谢你们加入我。你们所做的工作非常重要，所以非常感谢。谢谢。这是我的荣幸。是的，谢谢你们邀请我们。你可以在我们的网站speakingofpsychology.org或Apple、Spotify、YouTube或任何你获取播客的地方找到《心理学谈话》之前的剧集。如果你喜欢你所听到的内容，请订阅并留下评论。如果你对未来的剧集有评论或想法，你可以发送电子邮件至speakingofpsychology@APA.org。
Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Warneman. Thank you for listening. for the American Psychological Association. I'm Kim Mills. Enjoy more ways to save at Ralph's, like low prices in every aisle. And when you download the Ralph's app, you can clip and save more with digital coupons every week.
《心理学谈话》由Lee Warneman制作。感谢您的收听。代表美国心理学会。我是Kim Mills。在Ralph's享受更多省钱方式，比如每个过道的低价。当你下载Ralph's应用程序时，你每周都可以通过数字优惠券剪辑并节省更多。
Plus, you can earn fuel points to save up to $1 per gallon at the pump. At Ralph's, you can enjoy more ways to save and more rewards every time you shop. So it's always easy to save big every day with savings and rewards. Ralph's SoCal for over 150 years, Savings may vary by state. Fuel restrictions apply. See site for details. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
此外，你还可以赚取燃油积分，在加油站每加仑最多可节省1美元。在Ralph's，你每次购物都能享受更多省钱方式和更多奖励。因此，通过储蓄和奖励，每天都能轻松省大钱。Ralph's SoCal 150多年来，储蓄可能因州而异。适用燃油限制。详情请见网站。本集暂无评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。